what's going on mosey nation this is
alex hormozy your host and uh most legit
youtuber with the best setup in
existence including my mom's basement
i'm kidding this is a 5 million condo
and i just happen to not like windows
where i work that being said the purpose
of this video is to blow up some of the
things that i saw online with relation
to
how to make more money when it comes to
getting a raise if you are an employee
number one or number two getting a raise
from your customers as a business owner
because at the end of the day all of us
are still beholden to our customers that
we serve and so if you don't know who i
am my name's alex from mozzie on
acquisition.com it's a portfolio of
companies that's over 100 million a year
and i have nothing to sell you and i
make these videos because i think it's
fun so let's rock and roll so i think
the easiest way to solve this dilemma or
this problem for not getting paid enough
is to understand what are the variables
that influence pay right right damn
right and so i think a fun process is to
go through this and think about it using
inversion thinking all right which is
something that charlie munger champions
and a lot of other great thinkers and so
if we wanted to and this would be the
problem that we're solving for if we
wanted to make as little money as
humanly possible and we were employees
and or business owners what would we do
well number one we would provide very
little value all right that'll be the
first thing that we do is we'd have we'd
have a skill set that that just does not
provide a significant amount of value to
a business and or to a customer all
right that's first off is what we would
do the second thing that we would do is
we would not ask for very much of that
of that value that we were creating so
hopefully we're creating some level of
value which is why we're getting
employed or where why we're asked to
solve some problem for a customer right
we're solving a problem there's a job to
be done that is the value that is the
potential amount of money that we can
earn the amount of that potential money
that we earn is dit is predicated based
on our ability to negotiate and so we
ask for a very small amount of that
money all right so low value and then of
that small number we ask even for a
smaller percentage of that number
because of our ability to negotiate
that would normally be the only two
things that you'd think okay well this
is my potential and this is how much i
ask for and so those are the only two
variables that that would create how
much i'm getting paid ah but there's a
third all right and i'm going to get to
the three and how you can flip this at
the end of the video all right but the
third one that we're going to look at is
supply demand dynamics meaning how
easily replaceable is the value that
we're providing and so in an unideal
world in bizarro land where we want to
get paid as little as possible using
inversion thinking we would one have low
value two ask for very little of it and
three have a line of people standing
behind us the opposite of scarcity right
uh working against us we are
commoditized our skill is easily found
and easily replaced by other willing
people who want to do it for less money
right because they hate us they hate the
economy they hate capitalism and they
hate generally moving up in life okay
so
if you are an employee or you are a
business owner and you are trying to get
paid more
then we can invert this process and
think to ourselves what are the ways
that we can number one
create more value which i wrote a whole
book about all right 100 offers 99 cents
if you want it number two
is how do we negotiate
now we have a high potential value that
we are creating right so we've now we've
flipped the equation we're creating
we're creating tremendous amount of
value for the person now one of the keys
in communicating value is
using multiple lenses through it to see
it all right so it's not just about um
and the easiest one is just the
quantitative number
value in terms of how much money
are we are we creating right how much
money are we helping to produce all
right so that is monetary value there
are other forms of value right there's
lots of services out there that exist
that especially consumer services where
there is no direct amount of value but
there's indirect value so if you help
someone lose weight the amount that you
can charge on that will depend on who
you serve right which would then
actually get into a fourth bucket which
is picking the right customers right and
i'll tell you a quick story about this
before i dive back in i think you'll
like the tangent so there's a boy and
he's 16 years old and he's you know
looking to get his first car and his
father one day surprises him with the
vehicle right so he's super excited he
sees the car but it's a little bit of a
clunker it's an old you know it's an old
car right but he's fine with it and the
dad says hey if you want you can go cash
this in um and then get you know and
then use the money to get something else
if you want and he says okay so he says
hey why don't you just go down to the
you know the the car lot and see uh see
what they'll give you for it so he goes
over the car a lot you know excited to
see what they'll trade trade the car in
for and they said you know what uh we'll
give you five thousand dollars for the
car and he was like okay so he goes back
to his dad tells him the story he says
okay son well why don't you why don't
you try the pawn shop see what see what
they'll give you for like the scrap yard
so he goes over to the pawn shop
scrap yard right goes there and uh and
and he asked the same question he says
you know this is the car how much can i
get for it they're like ah we'll
probably give you a thousand bucks just
for like the parts in the medal and he's
like so he walks back defeatedly to his
dad and he's like you know it's only
worth a thousand dollars to those guys
stats says hmm why don't you go down to
that antique dealership see what they
say so he goes to the antique dealership
shows them the car and they say oh my
god this is a historic xyz car there's
only this many of them ever made this is
a 200 000 vehicle the kid
blown out of his mind runs back home
he's like dad you won't believe it and
the dad smiles and he's like what it's
like they say this car is unbelievably
valuable it's historic it's like one of
a kind blah blah blah and so the dad
pauses and says so listen son what i
want you to see from this is that the
value that someone will give you is not
necessarily just
a result of the vehicle of who you are
but who you are talking to and so a
hidden bonus of this video that i'm
going to give you right now is that
there are three is what i said but the
fourth one
is who we are serving right so the
amount that you can charge if you are a
business owner will be also predicated
on who you serve right if you can help a
billionaire lose weight he will probably
pay you more than somebody who's on
who's on unemployment right just the
nature of like that problem to that
person is
more valuable to solve right and that's
because indirectly for them if that
helps the billionaire right get his wife
which he might value more right or he
might be able to seal a deal because
people respect him or whatever it is
right then there is more indirect value
that you can ascribe to the the services
that are being provided okay so i said
there were three but there's actually
four because i'm trying to keep you
interested in the video right keep keep
going keep it keep you guessing all
right but so i said number one was value
okay so values can be predicated on who
we're serving and also how much value we
can provide which is going to come into
what's the dream outcome we're providing
them how likely do they think that
they're going to get that with you as an
employee and or as a business they're
hiring because all of us are doing jobs
all of us are employees right in one way
or another how quickly we can get that
done
and then how much work they have to do
as a result of that which you can
translate in a couple ways if you're an
employee and someone always has to check
up on you and always has to give you
direct instructions that is less
valuable of employee than somebody that
employee who's coming with the ideas can
get things done quickly i have a large
amount of confidence that someone's
going to do the job and the perceived
outcome that i that i want to create
that employee can duplicate quickly
awesome so that's you can reverse the
value equation that i talk about in the
book whether you're working for a
customer or you're working for a boss
either of those things and i'll get to
how you can make more money as an
employee in a second okay so one we're
flipping the inversion to we create lots
of value number two is going to be how
much we ask for all right so how much we
negotiate and so as a
business we do this by setting our
prices right that is that is
fundamentally the negotiation that
occurs is that we set our prices and a
lot of times you'd be amazed that just
asking for more you get more right
because most people sell from their own
wallet as in they think this is a lot of
money and therefore they ask for what
they believe is a lot of money and
here's the fundamental fallacy with this
problem what comes easy to you
is typically not easy for other people
and so i'll give you a simple example
personally i am not a car guy i am not a
fix-it guy i i just don't care and so if
i went to a mechanic shop and they said
hey we've gotta you know change your oil
and actually you know do xyz in your car
it's gonna be you know 100 bucks if they
say 100 bucks or 300 bucks it's it
really isn't gonna i like i'm not gonna
notice i'm not gonna care but if you
talk to another mechanic they're like
you charge that guy 200 to change his
oil that's crazy it only takes two
seconds and all you have to do is turn
the knob and the oil comes out and then
pour it back in whatever right and it's
because to them to a mechanic changing
oil seems like a very easy thing to do
and it probably is but to me it's
something that is going to take me time
to learn that i don't care and so what
is easy to one person because you have
been doing it for so long might not
necessarily be easy to other people and
so your perception of the value is
actually skewed which is why you should
not be the one necessarily setting your
prices you allow the market to set the
prices for your services and or the pay
that you get so number one we provide
lots of value number two you negotiate
or ask for a higher amount okay and if
you're an employee an easy way to do
that is create some sort of variable
compensation for yourself and say hey
these are ways that i think i can tie
into the revenue of the business would
it be fair would it be unreasonable for
me to ask for a percentage of that not
for the necessarily the whole company
but at least in this way so that i can
drive towards those goals which will
also make the company more money which
is exactly what we're doing as a you
know when we serve uh customers right
especially if you're in b2b services you
say listen i think that this thing will
yield this amount of results and i would
like a percentage of that right and it's
variable compensation so the best way
and the highest people who make the most
money have variable compensation
business owners have variable
compensation depends on how well your
business does and how how much you serve
your customers the business itself is
variable compensation right the
enterprise value all right so if you can
shift your thinking around this it will
pay dividends so value negotiations go
and the third one which is competitive
landscape competitive dynamics or supply
demand for the job to be done all right
so think about this way if i have lots
of people who can do the job if i have
somebody who comes up to me let's say
they're an employee and they say hey i'm
providing lots of value and i would like
to ask for more i would not have
leverage on this situation if there was
20 other people who were lined up who
could do the job and were willing to
accept less which is why this applies
for both labor as it does for owning a
business it's both sides right if i want
to provide xyz service and there's
another guy who's willing to provide xyz
service for less and there's nothing
that really differentiates us then most
consumers will just go to the one that
costs less which brings up the important
lesson of how do you invert this how do
we solve this problem which is we have
to be in a category of one all right and
so we do this by trying to niche down
and create more specialized services
because then we decrease the pool of
people that we are competing against now
as you scale up in a business i'm going
to answer this as a business and also
for employees as you scale up in a
business you do in general go broader
but usually you can use the experience
the depth of knowledge you have and then
be able to be better at that stuff at a
larger scale and so the easiest thing to
do which is why i talk about this in the
book is is is niche down at first right
so that we can get really really good at
delivering one very specific high amount
of value to a very specific customer
right and so when we do that we
basically fall into creating lots of
value we price high so we're asking for
a bigger percentage of the value that we
know we're creating and we're doing it
as a category of one in that there's no
other people who can do it and so we add
other features and bells and whistles
and bonuses and guarantees to create
offers that are more compelling to a
customer that are one of a kind which
make it more difficult for other people
to compete against us and thereby allow
us to capture a larger percentage of the
value that we are creating that's the
idea that's the point now if you're an
employee and you walk through this
process then the idea is how can i use
my unique unique being the key
skills and experiences to make the
business that i'm working for more money
right because ultimately that is i mean
that's where you're getting compensated
it's a percentage of the revenue that
you're responsible for right indirectly
or directly and the more directly you
can be associated with it the more you
will get compensated because the more
clearly you can point to the value that
you are creating right because the more
direct it is the less argumentation or
discount that will be applied to the
value that you're creating for the
business right does that make sense
hopefully it makes sense okay so if we
are an employee and we want to make more
money then we're going to use our unique
skills and experiences and we're going
to try and quantify to the highest
degree possible how we can directly
impact the bottom line of the business
we're going to ask for variable
compensation around the value that we
are providing for the business which
just works the same if you're if you're
a business and we're going to be able to
get it and this is the the third piece
here the reason that we're going to be
able to get it is because no one else
can do it all right and that's the idea
and so this also kind of brings in that
part that the bonus number four which is
the type of opportunity that you are
pursuing in terms of the overarching
umbrella of business that you are
working for will also dictate how much
you get paid right like if you work at a
dry cleaning business it will be very
difficult for you to make a million
dollars a year and that's because the
business doesn't make a million dollars
a year in all likelihood right and so
your opportunity vehicle will always be
a subset of the business opportunity
that you're working underneath of and i
think this is a good thing to to hit on
because uh what it takes which is a
great book by stuart uh stuart
schwartzman stephen schwartzman
star the guy started blackstone okay
anyways that guy all right he's worth 37
billion dollars today so he's pretty
rich he's pretty good and what he talks
about is the idea and i think many other
visionaries have said this but you need
to have a vision that is big enough for
your business that others people's
visions fit inside of it and so what
that really means is that you need to
have a pie that's big enough that
everyone can get wealthy and if you're
operating in an opportunity vehicle that
does not allow other people to get
wealthy then you will probably not
attract 10 out of 10 talent and if you
are 10 out of 10 talent then maybe you
should be looking for bigger visions
bigger visionaries bigger companies who
have bigger goals and bigger dreams so
that you can learn unique expertise
while working at those businesses
because listening to uncle warren
there's only two things you should be
working for whether you're learning or
you're earning right so you should get
paid you should get paid in one or two
or ideally both ways when you work which
you should be learning all the time and
you should be earning right and it
should definitely at least be one of
those two things and if you're not
learning and you're not earning you
should stop working wherever you're
working all right which is why we're
seeing a precipitous drop in i would say
frontline retail very generic workers
last two months i think we have eight
million people quit their jobs in those
kind of uh frontline sectors because the
opportunity was not big enough right and
so for us we can think about this as
business owners when we're thinking
about our employees we can think we have
as business owners as we're
communicating value to our customers
which is how can i create the value how
can i how can i capture the value
through my pricing and my ability to
negotiate and then how can i create a
category once i'm not competing it's
everyone else's shitty prices and so as
the employee we do the exact same thing
except our prices are the wages that we
charge and so in that way being a
business business owner or an employee
actually is very similar it's just that
we are just one degree separated from
the customer right so the business owner
is closer to the customer than the
employee that works for the business
from a value creation standpoint
business serves the customer employees
search the business right and they do
that i say that as a from a big picture
perspective even though the employee may
directly be uh servicing the customer
they do it within the overarching
infrastructure of the business that
exists all right and so right now if you
want to make more money you want to get
paid more whether you are a business
owner or an employee think about how you
measure up in each of those three
dynamics and if you're like how do i
create more value i wrote a book about
it it's 99 cents you can grab it if you
want it's on amazon it's thousand five
star reviews i think people like it at
least or at least they just like leaving
five star reviews for it so either way
i'm cool with it um ideally they like it
though
but that's about the the value creation
your ability to negotiate honestly like
you could have all the tips in the world
i'll tell you the simple simplest law of
negotiation is this he who has the most
options wins the circumstance and so
your ability to get other customers your
ability to have other jobs if you're an
employee those that you that you bring
to the table prior to your negotiation
will give you all the leverage you need
if you have a hundred girls who are
lined up to date you or a hundred guys
who are lined up to date you you have
more leverage in the quote negotiation
if you have if hundreds of other
businesses who want you you have far
more ability to negotiate which is why
people are like how does the ceo make 50
million dollar bonus or whatever from
his public traded companies he's like
well do you know the amount of guys who
can do that specific job you can count
on one hand in the entire planet right
and so that is why because the supply
demand dynamics for that specific role
right and the value that's being created
and the percentage that they negotiate
that's how that kind of money gets
created you can make obscene amounts of
money as both a business owner and or an
employee as long as you understand those
three dynamics all right and as again
the added bonded caveat to that is that
those guys can make that kind of money
because they're operating within a
business that has a massive dream that
is really to impact humanity overall and
lots of people can get wealthy in that
both the owners and the employees
because in a lot of ways the
compensation structure the bonuses
options things like that they structure
are based on variable compensation on
the overall production of the business
all right so um lots of love everyone if
you're new to mozzie nation welcome and
i will see you guys in the next video